the david pakman show depends on the
support of our audience our primary
source of funding is the membership
program we have on our website
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
day called the bonus show for our
members oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad well
okay i wouldn't call it quite so bad
it's just an extra show alex but thank
you you can sign up at joinpacman.com
and you can use the coupon code big
voting 22 to get a sizeable discount off
of the cost of a membership hope to see
you
on today's bonus show jenny thomas's
lawyer says she's just too stressed out
to testify because of what's going on in
the united states today yes it's uh
beyond parody so let's back up a little
bit clarence thomas is a supreme court
justice ginny thomas is the wife of
clarence thomas jenny thomas we now know
was very much involved in the fake
elector scheme of the 2022 election
trying to send fake electors to
washington dc
to vote for trump instead of joe biden
despite joe biden having won their state
this includes arizona she was heavily
involved in the um
lead up to the january 6th rally that
donald trump did before the riot ginny
thomas is very involved
and this also puts clarence thomas in a
potentially compromising position where
many are saying he should really recuse
himself from anything even remotely
having to do with the 2020 election the
january 6 committee now wants to hear
from her and her lawyer says guys she's
just too stressed out and this is only
days after she said she was eager to
testify yet again
oh i want to tell my side okay we'll
show up and swear an oath oh i'm too
stressed now i can't do it business
insider reports jenny thomas's lawyer
tries to get her out of the january 6
panel testimony saying it's been a
particularly stressful time amid all of
these supreme court rulings you've got
to be kidding me
the attorney for jenny thomas the wife
of supreme court justice clarence thomas
questioned the need for her testimony
before the january 6 committee and said
it had been a quote particularly
stressful time oh poor thing amid recent
supreme court rulings the house
committee investigating the capital riot
requested a voluntary interview with
thomas earlier this month over her
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
she didn't formally accept the
invitation but she said two weeks ago
she quote can't wait to speak to the
panel
okay
but in an eight-page letter sent on
tuesday thomas's attorney mark palletta
wrote he had quote serious concerns
about the interview asked the committee
to quote provide a better justification
for why her testimony would be relevant
and added in his letter i would also
note that this has been a particularly
stressful time as the thomases have been
subjected to an avalanche of death
threats and other abuse by the
unprecedented assault on the
conservative supreme court justices and
their families oh guys it's just too
stressful for her right now but of
course remember jenny thomas uh 14 days
ago i can't wait to talk to the january
6 committee and we'll quote clear up
misconceptions it sounds like two weeks
ago
she saw the opportunity to testify
or it wasn't even to testify it was an
informal interview to speak to the
january 6 committee as maybe a
stress-reducing thing i would love to
show up it would be so good for me
to reduce and clear up misconceptions
about my involvement cut to cut to this
week oh it's just way too stressful for
her way way way too stressful well
why not clear up the misconceptions
maybe the misconceptions aren't really
misconceptions maybe she really was as
involved as it's believed in the
attempts to overturn the 2020 election
did clarence thomas say oh hell no you
can't do that that's insane
did her lawyer say you know if you give
this informal interview the next step is
the committee might say well we need you
to testify under oath and then if you
don't then they might subpoena you and
maybe the conversation would reveal
additional information that's bad for
clarence thomas
guys she's married to a supreme court
justice
she must have known that this all could
lead towards sworn testimony in which
you would be bound to tell the truth and
this is straight out of the trump
playbook remember that one of the
classics of the trump playbook is
the principle it was often trump who
would do it he would say hell yeah i'll
show up
i'll clear all this up and it's because
trump thinks
he's smarter than everybody in the room
trump thinks he can lie and give his
false version of events and everybody's
going to fall for it nobody's going to
realize that the guy is lying and then
lawyers say oh there is no way you're
showing up in testifying under oath
remember that with the russia probe this
was a thing trump kept saying i can show
up and i'm going to tell him what's what
and of course every lawyer said oh dear
god
this guy lies uncontrollably if he shows
up and lies that's what others are
getting indicted and charged for and
found guilty of you can't do that you
tell everyone just how eager you are to
share your information you tell
everybody how eager you are to clarify
and then later someone else says oh yeah
no
here's the thing uh she's really
stressed out guys she can't show up and
that's exactly what happened with trump
in the russia probe and listen i'm open
to seeing do these secret service agents
testify do other aids to high-level
trump staff come in and contradict the
testimony of cassidy hutchinson bring
them in put them under oath and then
we'll keep it we'll consider it on an
equal playing field
otherwise it's just media nonsense and
the latest is ginny thomas is just too
stressed out to show up and clear up
everything just we're wrong about
everything we've said about her and she
would love to clear it up
but it's just too stressful for her
right now give me a break
i think this is the biggest discount
that any sponsor has ever offered on the
david pakman show this is crush organics
crush organics loves the show so much
they're giving my viewers 50 off their
entire collection of organic cbd
products when you use the code pacman
i'm the only show
where you can get this big a discount
that i like and for each sale crush
organics will donate 10 to the last
prisoner project that's a really great
non-profit helps to
free non-violent drug offenders and
reform drug laws very important and it
doesn't stop there anyone who uses my
code also gets a free jar
of cbd gummies or a jar of cbd topical
cream crush has only the best organic
cbd whether you're looking for oils
creams or edibles so that's 50 percent
off and a free jar of gummies or topical
cream and 10 bucks towards creating real
change in our justice system go to crush
organics dot u s
and use the code pacman the link is down
below